allez allez on y va
merci qui êtes vous monsieur le chef des
anneaux merci pantxo venezia nuova très
bien aller ça y est on a dit m de tf1 on
espère qu'on va pouvoir rentrer moi je
vais danser comme un fou là bas j'ai
envie de leur faire la fête et j'ai
envie de leur dire que je les aime
moncany t'as pas envie de leur dire tu
quand gm prépare à la corée depuis 48
heures allez c'est parti alors est-ce
qu'on va rentrer ça y est on y est alors
la regarder alors tf1 c'est la regarder
tf1 c'est là c'est cette grande tour
merci les chéris j'ai eu à regarder on a
même prévu un bouquet de fleurs merci
mes chéris d'avoir prévu un bouquet
comment ça va mais chéri alors mes
chéris bonjour je voudrais vous
remercier
merci à toi vous avez fermé depuis la
pop est venu est-ce qu'on veut pas
rentrer est-ce qu'on veut pas rentrer je
sais pas on attend la décision à ils
attendent la décision si on peut rentrer
ou pas alors est-ce que c'est ce que c
est ce que vous voyez à réméré les deux
mois prochain parce que lui il est déjà
parti desseigne et des partis ils ont
devancé les canadiens alors que gsk
pouvoir est ce que vous pouvez montrer
qu'on est bien enfin s'il vous plaît at
a les a donnés à paraître début 2008 le
shérif on va essayer dans l'eau
deuxième but départir alors monsieur
monsieur vous êtes de tf1 oui tout à
fait est-ce qu'on va rentrer ou pas on
peut pas entrer non on ne peut pas
entrer pour quelques vapeurs direction
ils vont venir vous voir
c'est vrai il arrive à les appeler ouest
où près les appréciera mais non ce que
j'ai une émission qui va se terminer
assez vite merci est-ce que vous pouvez
donner sa cavale si c'est juste pour les
renverser
merci voilà alors on va les remercier
merci à lui de la prouver gratuit julien
des rames à dire merci quand même et
gérard louvin voila voila merci de faim
voilà merci le shérif merci merci merci
de chialer merci de m'envoyer tentes
habitées
vous êtes des hindous tf1 vous aide
merci les chéris voilà merci à des fins
[Applaudissements]